antoine le kremlin paraît donc toujours
campé sur ses positions
oui tout à fait la position du président
russe reste inchangée depuis les
premiers résultats annoncés par les
médias américains
des résultats donnant job hayden
vainqueur de cette élection
à savoir pas de reconnaissance de cette
victoire sans proclamations officielles
et surtout tant que les recours de
donald trump ne trouve pas une issue
premièrement un président élu doit être
proclamé le président sortant doit
reconnaître les résultats des élections
et tous les procès juridique doivent
être achevés ce n'est qu'après cela que
le bilan des élections sera
officiellement proclamée de toute
évidence cela ne s'est pas encore
produit autrement dit vladimir poutine
ne s'exprimera sur le sujet seulement
lorsque seront épuisés tous les procès
et autres recours juridiques intentées
par le candidat républicain écouter ils
doivent tous être terminée sans cela les
élections ne seront pas officiellement
achevé c'est précisément ce que le
président a déjà dit à plusieurs
reprises et ont regardé difficultés
rencontrées par donald trump dans ses
différentes démarches judiciaires
c'est bien joe biden qui devraient être
proclamés 46e président des états unis
n'en déplaise à moscou qui s'attend à
des relations houleuses avec le nouveau
locataire de la maison blanche
quoi qu'il en soit de l'aveu même de
vladimir poutine ce sera difficile de
terriers de détériorer davantage des
relations russo américaines
déjà au plus bas merci anthony claireaux
en direct de moscou